hi everyone i'm coming at you from in
the middle of nature because i'm on a
kind of a vacation here but uh which is
also why
i'm not posting as many videos as usual
right now
but that doesn't mean i can't give you a
q a
i hope this the sound works because
there's a lot of wind right now so
we'll see how it goes
um this time i will only be answering
questions posed by my patreon community
because i got a lot of questions from my
patrons and that's going to take up all
of this video basically
again if you want to become a patron
yourself i will leave a link to all of
that stuff in the description
so yeah let's start answering some
questions question number one
uh by stephen phillips on patreon there
are scholars who raise questions about
the traditional narrative about
muhammad's life in mecca the hijrah and
the revelation of the quran some suggest
that the quran was compiled by a group
of authors in syria what do you know
about this scholarship and do you think
it is well founded
it seems to become more and more popular
these
sort of revisionist ideas about the
early days of islam
considering muhammad may have been
so there are theories that mecca is not
actually mecca but that the original
mecca was in
uh petra and they based this on certain
descriptions of mecca and the quran that
doesn't seem to
match up with the environments in mecca
itself talking about
trees and nature that doesn't exist
there etc
i think i think i've answered this
question in a live q and a ones i think
it's an interesting
theory i think all theories are welcome
i am not convinced by this theory yet
i think
there isn't enough
solid evidence i think to make that
claim but i do think that it is
definitely a legitimate thing to
do more research in i think i support
the scholars to do that stuff i think
because any any scholarship is welcome
of course
even if it does
raise some serious questions about our
common knowledge about a topic like that
alex m asked the question how much do
you think islam and christianity and
judaism for that matter
counter-influence each other with the
aquinas citing muslim theologians citing
islamic scholars in his writings and
people like maimonides how much you
think that plays into the evolution of
dogma in each religion
a lot of course
religions are always
influencing each other they're
co-mingling especially
in a place like the middle east for
example in the middle ages there were
muslims there were christians there were
jews there were people of other
religions of course
and they all influence each other
there's no denying that
we talk a lot about sufism on this
channel many scholarships they believe
that the early sufi ascetics were
influenced by
the christian monastics in the middle
east at that time
we see a lot of influence in islamic
philosophy or in the islamic
philosophers from neoplatonism which was
originally a pagan
well it was it was a philosophy that
emerged in a pagan environment
and the whole enterprise of kalam
abductional philosophical theology
within islam with the groups like the
ashadites and watashi and so on
historians argue that that whole
tradition of kalam emerged originally as
a result of the christians and their
very sophisticated
debates and discussions on theological
matters in the middle east and that the
muslims developed this tradition of
kalam as a way to respond to that and to
be able to counter uh the philosophical
and theological arguments by
the
christians
and then later on the middle ages you
see
the opposite happening of course the
islamic philosophers and the
philosophers in the islamic world
generally are hugely influential they
develop the greek philosophy and develop
new philosophies which becomes
incredibly
fruitful and important and this then
travels to europe and this influence
as you said it influences christian
theologians and philosophers like thomas
aquinas like i don't know maester
eckhardt
and again the same goes for jewish
philosophers maimonides and other jewish
philosophers within the islamic world
are influenced by islamic thinkers
and the islamic thinkers are influenced
by the jewish thinkers so this is always
happening like religions are influencing
each other philosophies are influencing
each other
uh
none of these religions would be where
they are and would have the history that
they have if they hadn't come into
contact with all these other traditions
so the influence is huge i would say
faram asks hi what is your earliest
memory of a religious thought
reflecting on some religious teaching as
an adult an adult shared with you or
wondering about the existence and a
creator as a child do you believe in
such a thing as an innate sense of
religiosity
i can't remember i think well as as
every child
or most children i guess i would lay
awake at night thinking about death and
things like that like
the idea of nothingness
whether or not death meant absolute
nothingness absolute annihilation that
was the thing and then the classic
question of
i remember having this thought as like
an 11 year old or maybe earlier maybe
like eight years old
i was
lying awake at night thinking about
colors so this very very common
philosophical question um
that i think everyone has at some point
which is like well i see so
does my green look the same
[Music]
to you like or if there are two people
do they see the color green in the same
way or the color yellow etc or or are
those colors somehow different for
different people like so i remember
having that
that thought
i think i always
had a sense that there was something
more to
to the argument than what was presented
by a lot of my atheist companions or or
family members or whatever
i always seem to be drawn to a more
subtle and complex view of the world
where the idea of a divinity
beyond the physical or material world
was always
attracted to me i guess and and
i remember having debates in high school
with people
like both atheists and theists we would
have like discussions and i would take
some sort of middle position
i was also probably influenced by
listening out to the beatles and to to
um
sort of
the 60s kind of [ __ ] counter culture
movement and all the spiritual aspects
of that i think
did influence me as a teenager etc
i don't know
so i think i think i don't think it's
much of a moment necessarily where i had
a profound spiritual religious thought
it's it's been more of a sort of gradual
development and change
over time
even as a child i would say farah also
asked are you familiar with integral
theory or spiral dynamics
if yes what do you think of the stages
of them i actually don't i haven't heard
of that i think so i should
i should check that out thank you for uh
suggesting it it sounds interesting
i'll i'll look it up okay so rob domos
asked a question a while ago i forgot to
answer it in the previous q a and i
apologize for that the question
basically is so he's stating so he's
commenting on the fact that a lot of um
sacred scriptures or important
scriptures and different religions seem
to appear
around the year 500 bc
or bce
and basically like why
why is that why do you think
that so many scriptures appear around
that time and i guess that's true to
some degree a lot of sections from the
bible
seem to have been
written around that time 500 ish bc this
is the time of the babylonian exile
you also have the upanishads which is by
scholars considered to have been to have
appeared at around that time
at least certain sections of the
upanishads you have the dow beijing
seems to have been written
around that time where a bit later you
have the johnson in china you have
the bhagavad-gita which appears
we don't know exactly but you know from
maybe 300 bc to
century to ce
um or ad
else there is a lot of there so you
can't deny that there's a lot of
scriptures that appear all the time i
don't know if i agree with the starting
assumption
to any huge degree i think i think there
are always scriptures appearing in
different times so you can look at you
know the sikh scriptures the guru granth
sahib that appears in the 16th century
right
or at least
it's compiled at around that time
the bible or the new testament appears
later on the quran comes
in the 600s a.d at the same time there
definitely is a lot of stuff happening
at around that time in greece you have
the
the appearance of philosophy basically
at around that time they're
pre-socratics you have you know
pythagoras and
and uh
prime enemies and all these people
so there's something happening the
buddha also and jainism
appears at around this time
i think it may have something to do with
writing
there's a lot more
writing down of things at around that
time you know the bible is being written
down
whereas previously it might have been an
oral thing
the upanishads also
which
is still really mostly an oral thing
and i'm not an expert on this particular
subject that i believe that it is around
the time this time that things start to
be written down
uh the philosophers
in greece they also would actually write
at least you know plato and aristotle
they would write things and the same
goes for china i don't know if there's a
connection between all of these
in that sense it may be a coincidence
that it all appears at around this time
but i think it may have something to do
with with writing and the development of
writing and the way that writing is used
the way that writing is employed
and is being seen as a more legitimate
way
of teaching
religious or philosophical thoughts as
opposed to orally which was for them for
most of history really has been the way
that things are taught so teacher
student oral teaching um i if i'm not
mistaken i believe it is around this
time that we start to see writing being
employed a lot more so i think that
might be
this is a sort of
wild but
i guess a bit educated guess
is that it has something to do with
writing and the fact that writing
preserves things in a very different way
than simply oral teaching that would be
my guess that if anything if there's any
connection here
i would say it has something to do with
that
so ralph nisel asks all religions in
some way discuss meaning of life
and what is you would say the lowest
common denominator between the religions
that's really hard to say because
religion is such a
religion as a concept it's a construct
like any other religion or sorry like
any other
concept like that it's a western word
that's applied to a lot of different
things that don't necessarily connect to
each other
a lot of people
a common way to define religion at least
in a sort of protestant european
environment is to say that has something
to do with belief like belief in the god
but then like what do you do with
buddhism
which
isn't
a common i think a common
misunderstanding is that it's atheist
it's not atheist but it doesn't require
the belief in a god so that's not a
central aspect of what that is
but
should we then consider buddhism to not
be a religion i wouldn't say so
so religion i think is a very complex
term and i think it's hard to to talk
about something that connects all of
them to me
religion is primarily something about
life also a dork i mean
sociological perspective on religion
where what makes a religion a religion
or what the the basic human function of
religion is primarily i would say is
social
that it has to do with the social
cohesion and forming groups
and and of belonging
you know sort of identity formation and
to belong into a certain group
sort of forming these
in groups and out groups and so i think
that's what religion premier is about a
sense of belonging to something
so maybe that's my answer to that is
that it's something that
gives someone a sense of identity and a
sense of belonging to something greater
than themselves i guess or to to a sort
of a group or a more abstract structure
i would say uh ralph again asked do you
think the religions give better answers
than others as philosophers scientists
regarding the why question and meaning
of life discussions that is why is there
any meaning at all for us humans to live
on was the higher purpose of our lives
well science don't seem to
be interested in those kinds of
questions mostly
that isn't to say that scientists aren't
interested in that but uh science is
it's a method right so it's it talks
about the how of things it can it can
map the
at least so at least the modern
understanding of the word science and we
talk about science a few hundred years
ago there would be a different idea what
science is which would include things
like metaphysics perhaps
but as it stands right now i think
science is most interested in mapping
the physical and material world
how things work
and why they work as they work but not
necessarily
the sort of grand why question
and so your question is does religion
give a better answer to that and i well
it at least tries to
sometimes
but there are of course as you know so
many religions and so many philosophies
that
they sort of cancel each other out
sometimes i would say i could argue that
you can find common common ideas and
common themes within different
philosophies and religions that might
appear to be somehow universally true
etc but
in general religions are so diverse that
i wouldn't go as far as to say that it
gives a better answer
but i will give it
that it tries to give us the answer it
attempts to
talk about those questions it talks
about metaphysical questions it asks
okay well this is how the universe began
but why did it begin
and i don't know maybe there doesn't
need to be a why but i think religion
sometimes at least
or a lot of the time
they are occupied with trying to answer
those questions third question from
ralph i have the recent period started
to use the expression spirit of the
universe instead of god do you also
think it can be useful when discussing
and comparing religions and spirituality
sometimes yes sometimes not i think
spirit of the universe implies a kind of
monistic and not necessarily but a kind
of pantheistic
imminentist view of what god is
so if we talk about advaita vedanta or
we talk about taoism
so we talk about the tao and taoism
where we talk about
god as understood by certain
mystics in the different monotheistic
religions for example then
spirit of the universe spirit of the
universe wouldn't be entirely
wrong to say even in something like
sufism which is comes from a
monotheistic environment
god is sometimes described i think it
was al-jili abdul karim al-jili who
describes god as the soul of my soul
which is kind of nice and it's kind of a
similar idea
but
but uh but if we consider other
expressions of religion which isn't as
focused on the imminentist view of god
but in instead of god as transcendent as
being different from creation the sort
of classic
standard understanding of monotheism
then spirits of the universe i don't
wouldn't fit all too well so i wouldn't
apply a term like that to all religion
or to god as a general concept but maybe
to certain understandings of god sure
yahya bashandi asked were there any
muslim commerce to christianity or
judaism or any other religion was it
common how did the authorities deal with
it how did the local clerics respond to
it and what was the treatment of the
converts by the authorities
so did it happen yes there were muslims
in the early there has always been
muslims right converted to christianity
to uh judaism etc was it common well
that depends on the period we're talking
about in some periods it was more common
than in other periods
um so that's a difficult question to
answer but so what was the treatment of
these people orthogen the attitude of
the clerics
so
a commonly known
thing which is often discussed when
talking about islam and
in the contemporary world is the fact
that apostates
are often given the death sentence
within islam and that was true early on
as well
the idea of someone leaving the religion
and instead becoming or joining some
other group
was seen as a form of treason so you
have to remember that
in the early days especially of the
prophet muhammad if
and he was
basically
in at war in conflict with other
groups in in arabia who are pagans etc
and if someone had
if someone left islam so to say and
joined the other religion that was from
a treason that meant that you joined the
other army
that were trying to kill you so
many argue that that is where that idea
comes from that the idea of an apostate
or the fact that an apostate should be
should face capital punishment for that
and that was the general i would say the
majority position
um i mean don't quote me on it but i'm
pretty sure that was the majority
opinion of
jurists and scholars in in the early
days of islam now that doesn't mean that
as soon as someone um
converted to christianity they beheaded
him of course there were there was a
process a
legal process and they were often given
a lot of opportunity to
to repent so the first
step would be to ask them to repent if
they
refused to repent they would be placed
in prison
and they would
be in prison and people the clerics or
the authorities would try to try to
pressure them to recant their conversion
and come back to islam and then if
nothing worked then indeed
the capital punishment would be
applied now that is
the you could say the
ideal of the
of the jurists right of according to the
sharia or islamic law and that was what
jurists would declare in fatwas for
example so legal opinions those fatwas
were never
binding to the authorities so the
authorities could choose to not apply
them they could choose to ignore them
and so there were converts who weren't
killed of course but in terms of like
the general attitude of the the scholars
or the jurists and and how they
approached that
question that was uh
that was a general way that that was
seen that if someone
left islam then that they that
warranted that they'd be killed
although after a long process of
allowing them the ability to repent or
recant that conversion
hirshikesh dwan asks you touched on this
in one of your videos on hinduism
what but do you think it qualifies as an
ism
i was born into hindu family and grew up
a skeptic
eventually an atheist the more i learned
about hinduism the more i realized it
was an exonym given to a way of life by
colonialist hive mind and you can't
really compare it to say islam
christianity because there is no central
creed catechism or practices that
actually make it in ism i take your
point about it being a religion in that
it is a set of correlated practices that
about a billion people follow but isn't
that broad is it too broad to be ism
hinduism is a complex topic right
so hinduism
some some people argue that it shouldn't
even be seen as a religion
that it really is multiple religions
that is sort of collected under this
umbrella term i won't go that far as
i've stated in my video on the vedas i
would say that it's definitely an
umbrella term of sorts for a collection
of religious traditions in india or the
indian subcontinent
but that they
are connected enough
for us to be able to use a term like a
religion for it now ism is a very
complex term i don't like it usually
isn't isn't
applicable because most religions and
most movements that that are termed isms
are too complex to to use that term even
something like sufism like that's
so ism i don't like isms
generally um
but but hinduism is a special case
because it is such a complex and
multifaceted tradition
i've seen many people so here's the
thing i've seen many people say the
hinduism isn't a religion it's a way of
life
but that's such a
it's a strange position to hold because
which religion
is not a way of life
all religions see themselves as a way of
life it's not just about a belief in a
god
um
it's a whole
religions are often a whole system a
social system
of how to live your life how to live
alongside other people etc
but
so i don't agree with with that
statement
like
the idea that hinduism is more of a way
of life than or ways of life in this
case than
they are of religion but i definitely
agree with the idea that hinduism is a
tradition that is so complicated that
using things like isms or placing it
under the category of a religion
can become
a problem right it can become
problematic when we consider it's huge
diversity
again this is also of course true for
most religions christianity is hugely
diverse islam is hugely diverse there's
a whole host of different traditions
within all of those terms
even if they are considered
unitary religions but but again like
hinduism is
perhaps even more so like it is a hugely
diverse tradition
um so yeah i agree with you i think i
think
in some sense
just using the word ism doesn't capture
the complexity of hinduism
i don't know if i would i would
say that we should replace that term but
there is definitely a point in in
asking questions about whether or not
it's an accurate term and i would say
that in some ways it isn't
but yeah it's a complicated topic rick
chatterjee asked how did bulesha become
such a common subject matter in sufi
rock music that's a very good question
um so bulesha is a very famous sufi poet
from
northern india i think where pakistan
like northern indian subcontinent right
and there are a lot of sufi music
as many of you might know and a lot of
super music that employs sort of
contemporary musical genres like rock so
there is this thing sometimes sometimes
referred to as sufi rock
and it seems that a lot of sufi music
like contemporary civic music
employ the poetry of bulesha like i've
since you point this out that must be
the case and i think i've noticed that
too that he seems to be a very popular
poet in that regard
i think it's just a matter of region
right that
he is a very popular part in a certain
region and that in that region those
kinds of musical expressions are
are common
in certain parts we listen to koala
music for example the poetry of amir
khuzro
is like by far probably the most
commonly employed
so i think it's just a matter of
popularity and regional preferences but
up so
i would love to look
further into that subject because that's
very interesting but that would be my
guess we have our fourth question from
ralph he asked do you know if there are
any well functioning human communities
existing today that have survived for
long periods without having an active
organized religion within its community
if not what could we learn
can religion be replaced by something
else or comparable such as science
philosophy or spirituality without
religion these questions are all
dependent and the answers to these
questions are all dependent on how we
define all of these terms what does
religion mean
what does spirituality mean what is the
difference between spirituality and
religion
what's the difference between science
and like it becomes
such a complicated topic and
you might mean one thing when you ask
those questions and i might
mean something else when i read them or
answer them but
so as i said previously i define
religion primarily as a as a way of of
social cohesion and of identity
formation
defined as such i don't think humans can
live without religion i think there is
something inherent in us
that
so in our nature basically that that
makes us
crave
that kind of
belonging
and that we naturally create those kinds
of structures around us
that
um
become what we call religions
you know there might be an argument for
the fact that we need to make sense of
the world the classic uh definition of
religion by the scholar clifford geertz
is basically that religion is a way of
creating symbols
that make sense of a chaotic world
so that's more of a sort of
definition definition of religion that
exists in a kind of psychological
field like understanding religion as
this way of us to create meaning in a
seemingly meaningless world
i don't know if i
i don't necessarily follow that school
of thought i'm more in this sociological
camp but i think that that also the
psychological aspect is should
definitely be considered an aspect of it
i think they all kind of work together
and so
i think there is something inherent in
our humanity that just makes us form
these kinds of
structures and these ideas about the
world
in order for it for us to be able to
function
so i don't know if there's any community
that has existed without religion at
least to be defined religion as broadly
as i have there's usually that kind of
aspect to any community i can't think of
any that don't have that in history
even a secular world like today we still
have
the same kind of structures we just
don't call it religion we don't
necessarily apply gods to it but again
as we said there are many religions that
don't have gods so what's the difference
right
um
so no i think it's a it's definitely a
human
something about human nature that simply
just
needs religion
whether they ca so you are also asked
like if you're replaced by science or
i don't think so i think even the
findings of science will allow us to
form new structures around those
findings or those truths that are
expressed by science so i think science
as a method is something else right and
religion is this other
function of your society
that can of course mingle with science
and that science can be an aspect of
that or spirituality or how you define
and contrast these terms i think they
all can work together but there's this
there's this need in human beings for
uh this kind of expression this kind of
social cohesion in a way that um yeah
that's my stance at least i am
completely ready to be
for counter arguments to that but uh
that seems to be where i land on these
topics most of the time
subtitles what do you think is the role
of culture and religion the same
religion practice in different
geographical places take on the culture
of the place in the day to day rituals
and practices so adherents belong to one
religion but different cultural
sometimes create diverse versions of the
same religion definitely i mean culture
so the number one i don't know if
there's a difference between culture and
religion and i think dividing these two
categories into distinct categories is a
mistake because i think they are in some
ways the same thing and they you can't
really separate them this is this was
the arguments of the palestinian scholar
tala assad
also that we in the west or in the
modern world we separate aspects of
society like culture religion
sports uh science etc
in ways that have never been the case
historically before for the most part at
least
and that to do so is a mistake and or at
least is a
way of misunderstanding
how these things work they aren't
separate categories culture and religion
is the same thing which is why in some
senses at least it's the same thing
which is why your next point is it's
very much true like of course a religion
that comes through a
foreign environment will adapt aspects
of that culture so you look at a
religion like islam islam in morocco
looks very different from islam in
indonesia
there are of course certain
core features sometimes that are
universal in both of those cases but
they in some sense that they will look
very very different
this is the case for most religions
unless it's like a really fundamentalist
kind of puritanical aspect of a certain
religion
but even in those cases that that can't
be escaped there's always this
influence
migration makes a huge difference right
so people who migrate from the middle
east to the united states those migrants
united states will adopt
aspects of the
culture the environment in the
in the united states which in turn will
also affect how the people at home in
the middle east will also
conceive of themselves and of their
faith and their practice and so on so
it's a it's a network it's really a
network of interconnected um
experiences interconnected uh
aspects that all play into the same that
all create the environment and the the
religion or culture
that that emerges or that that is
expressed i think
yeah i think culture and religion
as such
is sometimes the same thing and at the
very least are hugely interconnected and
hugely influences each other in that
sense so yeah i think you make a very
good point in your question okay second
question from septage how do you
separate the philosophy of religion from
the practice of the religion every
religion that exists
philosophizes of a set of universal
truths and beliefs in humanity and
coexistence
yeah
so the philosophy of religion versus the
practice of a religion
this is a huge topic
so which comes first the practice or the
philosophy the ritual or the
rationalization of the ritual
scholarship today tends to lean towards
the latter that it is the ritual the
practice that comes first
we we are ritual creatures we're
performative creatures we do things and
we
rationalize and apply meaning to those
rituals
after the fact so that the
philosophy behind it is secondary
um i think that's a
legitimate position
this would really need like a whole
series of videos actually on my master's
thesis this was one of the the
main topics one of the sort of main
theoretical frameworks that i used was
this this idea of virtualization and how
ritual
um
ritual practice is basically connected
to
uh religious belief and so on i think
this is it's a it's a huge topic that
has been written a lot about in the last
couple of decades
one important i think aspect of this is
which i think figures into this although
it's not exactly what you're talking
about here but it's this idea of lived
religion which means that there is
usually
two facets of religion you could say
at least in this context so you have the
religion as the ideal status
state of a religion i ask conceived of
acid by its scholars by its great
books or you know in the universities or
whatever you have
certain ideas about what religion is but
then on the grounds
you know how normal people actually live
their religion can be very very
different
there is sometimes this dichotomy
between the the the sort of
i don't remember what term is used but
this basically
let's use the word ideal form of the
religion and then the lived religion and
the field of studying the actual lived
religion has become a lot more prominent
in the last couple of decades as well
that we shouldn't focus too much on
the philosophies as your question
uh
presumes as in talking about like what
does the religion teach
what how
what is the stance of
of islam on
music or whatever it may be but instead
to actually study muslims like
on people normal people in their
everyday lives how they
conceive of their religion how they
connected religion how they understand
that religion how they practice their
religion which is sometimes very
different from those
scholars or whatever
so that's a huge field there's a book by
there's a book by meredith mcguire
called lived religion
which has become a huge classic in
religious studies
so definitely you guys should check that
book out if you're interested in this
kind of topic pharah is back and asks
what is your take and opinion on the
connection between abraham and sarah and
brahma saraswati as figures of abrahamic
and hindu religions i haven't heard of
that connection before actually
so i don't really know i can't really
i can't really comment on on that so
there's a question of course
whether or not abraham
and that whole story
are they historical figures or are they
mythical figures we don't know i think
scholarship tends to lean to the idea
that they are mythical figures rather
than historical ones
but i haven't
so that course complicates the question
but i haven't even heard this particular
idea before about the connection to
hindu religion it seems just judging
from the names it seems like people may
connect
like the similarity in the names like
abraham brahma you have sort of
and sarah and saraswati like the names
are similar
and there are a lot of those kinds of
of linguistical similarities sometimes
between sanskrit or
like semitic languages but at the end of
the day like they are
completely separated language groups
doesn't say that they can't have
influence each other of course but i
think
a lot of the time when i see those kinds
of comparisons between words
it seems it's usually a bit far-fetched
so that's my sort of natural first
reaction to this it's like that seems
that seems a bit far-fetched but of
course i'm always open to any
possibility that would be an interesting
thing
to to
read more about but i can't comment more
on it than that nor awareness asks
hi i am curious to know how sufi culture
evolved in islamic culture islam being a
strong belief system and how can someone
from an intense conservative organized
religion culture think differently and
become broad-minded and a free thinker
sufism is based on love and compassion
and is liberal in the sense that they
are not interested in bullying anyone
you make a lot of assumptions in that
question
for example that sufism is based on love
and compassion or is liberal
and then implying thus that islam isn't
liberal and that isn't based on love and
compassion and that islam
is is based on or islam is at least
interested in bullying people
you also seem to
make the common mistake of separating
sufism from islam in some sense of
saying like how can sufism
appear in an islamic environment as if
they are different things sufism is
so understand me correctly is sufism is
islam right sufism is one expression of
islam it's not that sufism appears in
spite of islam that sufism appears in an
islamic environment
and as this sort of anomaly sufism is a
part of the
intellectual and spiritual development
of early islam that was one of the ways
that the muslims understood their
religion
which and and based that understanding
firmly in the quran and the hadiths
so i think
there's an inherent problematic
dichotomy in your question opposing
islam as a conservative
sort of strict
belief system and then having sufism as
something completely different but they
are they are intermingled so islam and
sufism is very much the same thing even
though some
muslims who don't believe so will say
that sufism has no part in islam
and that's a theological belief that you
can hold but in terms of his history and
in terms of looking at things from a
historical critical
neutral perspective right sufism is an
expression and a part of the islamic
religion and the islamic context more
generally right and so if we have a sufi
who is
liberal or consider or
emphasizes love and compassion that
means he's a muslim who is liberal and
emphasizes love and compassion
it's not that suddenly he is not a
muslim or that he is opposed to some
kind of grand islamic
attitude instead he is part of the
islamic
attitude right every muslim is part of
forming what islam is right islam
so there's this classic idea which i
discussed in the previous video right
that islam
so muslims create islam
rather than islam creating muslims right
so any muslim is a representative of
islam in some sense
um
and so again if sufism
is cons
sort of
if sufism is heavily concerned with love
and compassion and and charity and with
all these kinds of ideas and teachings
which they they are a lot of time not
always of course but sometimes that is a
huge emphasis within sufi movements then
that means that that is also an aspect
of islam it's not that that becomes some
other thing
in opposition to islam that becomes one
expression of islam
just like a more conservative strict
puritanical perhaps
expression of islam is also islam right
because religions are diverse they are
multifaceted and there are many
different people following that religion
who approach it differently but
nonetheless they all represent that
religion in some sense
so um yeah i guess that might that's
that's the best i can do in terms of an
answer for that
darjeeling trailblazer i love that name
i like your tease mr darjeeling
based on your knowledge would you regard
the five books of moses as a divinely
inspired revision of previously existing
mesopotamian mythos
okay let's take a break for a second
because my batteries and my camera died
i also realized that i was so much in
vacation mode that i didn't even bother
to check my hair before uh recording so
now i've i've also kind of made myself a
bit more um
respectable and rep representable i
guess um for this last question the
israelites the the authors of the hebrew
bible in the torah the five books of
moses in particular
figure in a cultural environment
where they
are neighbors with other cultures
who have intellectual traditions of
their own they are neighbored by the
canaanites by the egyptians by the
babylonians the persians
and all these people have
traditions and stories and and myths and
all this that
of course influence each other these
stories they travel
um and they are told in various ways and
they evolve and so on and so it's hard
to deny you can't deny that
there are stories and aspects of the
bible that are shared with other
cultures
in that region at that time because the
israelites were one among those cultures
and functioned in a similar way so we
have stories like the flood for example
which seems to be very similar to
stories from
babylonian literature for example
so in many ways yes like
the bible
you know regardless of your stance on
the bible and it's divine or not divine
nature
there's no denying the stories in the
bible
is somehow connected also to other
stories in cultures
at around that time it could be that
those stories come originally from the
biblical sources and that they spread to
other places afterwards or it could of
course be the case that these are
coincidences um but from historical
perspective it seems definitely that the
israelites were influenced by other
cultures and their intellectual uh and
literal literary traditions in various
ways so that's gonna have to be
everything for this time i hope i
remembered to answer all of the
questions by my patrons this was a lot
of fun
um i'm having a great time here on a
kind of vacation as i said
um
so it will take a it'll be a bit slower
in terms of uh
releasing new videos uh
uh now um but i'll be back pretty soon
i'll be making more videos
i have a few very exciting things
planned for the near future i did a poll
on my patreon page on what videos you
would like to see next and my patrons
got the opportunity to vote
and the video that got the most votes
was the video or a video on gnosticism
so a video what is narcissism will
basically be the title
um
now
that script is now finished i have
written that script and i'm very excited
about that
however that
video will be part of a collaboration
with another youtube channel that you
will have to wait and see which one
and so there's a bit more work
on that video that might
or might not take a little longer so i'm
not entirely sure if that's going to be
the next video because of these other
factors so i apologize if my poll was
give you the wrong impression i that is
the video of priority right now because
you voted for that video and that as i
said the script is done i am very much
looking forward to doing that
um
but if that's not the next video i'll be
choosing the second most voted on video
on the poll which was a video on dara
shuku the great grandson of akbar the
emperor akpa which was my last video
so
look forward to a video on darashuku
pretty soon look forward to a video on
gnosticism and a lot more fun stuff
thank you all for watching and i will
see you next time
[Music]
you